bonsoir à tous Bienvenue c'est le
journal de l'Afrique sur France 24 je
suis ravi de vous retrouver voici les
titres ce soir à la Une le gouvernement
éthiopien voit ça première délégation au
tigree depuis le début de la guerre
débuté en novembre 2020 objectif pouvoir
appliquer sur le terrain l'accord de
paix signé il y a deux mois entre
rebelle et pouvoir central à la Une
également la suite du bras de fer
judiciaire entre Jacob Zuma et Cyril
ramaosa l'ancien président sud-africain
accuse son successeur d'avoir commis un
crime l'actuel chef de l'État qui a mis
ses avocats sur le coup correspondance à
suivre et puis 100% d'inflation des prix
qui n'en finissent plus de grimper le
Soudan étant pleine crise économique la
population sur place manque de tout
c'est l'objet d'une série de trois
épisodes ne manquez pas le premier c'est
tout à l'heure
bienvenue sur notre antenne si vous nous
rejoignez c'est donc une étape
importante en vue de la paix pour la
première fois depuis deux ans une
délégation du gouvernement Nieto puis en
Éthiopie pardonnez-moi à poser le pied
dans la région rebelle du Tigré la
guerre je vous disais si est achevé en
novembre après la signature d'un accord
de paix la question désormais comment
l'appliquer Clément di Roma et notre
correspondance dans la région
pour la première fois en deux ans de
conflit une délégation du gouvernement
fédéral Ethiopien s'est rendu à Mesquer
les la capitale du tigree plusieurs
ministres dont ceux de la justice des
transports et des communications mais
aussi de l'industrie et du travail était
accompagné d'acteurs clés pour restaurer
les services de base dont la région est
privée depuis maintenant un an le groupe
mené par en conseiller du Premier
ministre devait superviser l'application
de l'accord de paix signée en Afrique du
Sud le 2 novembre dernier depuis cette
date les combats ont cessé les rebelles
ont annoncé avoir désengagé plus de la
moitié de leur combattants et la ville
de mekelé a été raccordée au réseau
électrique les représentants des deux
parties se sont rencontrés plusieurs
fois y compris le 22 décembre dernier
pour s'accorder sur un mécanisme de
suivi de l'accord de paix malgré ces
progrès les tigrés insistent sur le
retrait des forces série réels et des
Mélissa Mara soutient de l'armée
éthiopienne accusé d'exaction sur les
civils par des ONG et les autorités
rebelles enfin l'aide humanitaire arrive
très lentement dans la région selon les
Nations Unies des centaines de milliers
de personnes se trouvent dans des
conditions proches de la famine
le pays est habitué au feuilleton
judiciaire au plus haut sommet de l'État
en Afrique du Sud l'ancien président
Jacob Zuma et l'actuel Cyril Rama posa
ne se font aucun cadeau le premier à
attaquer en justice le second qui est
ensuite répliqué par le biais de ses
avocats l'affaire est éminemment
politique pour y voir plus clair les
explications de Caroline Dumay
pour mieux comprendre le front de cette
affaire il faut remonter un procès très
particulier ça fait plusieurs mois que
l'ancien président Jacob Zuma un très
long justice une journaliste locale
Karine Moon il l'accuse d'avoir divulgué
son secret médical d'avoir publié des
documents classiques confidentiels il
accuse également le parquet de lui avoir
fait suivre ces documents et bien
maintenant il accuse l'actuel président
Cyril Rama posa d'être complice de la
violation de ce secret judiciaire car il
n'a pas sanctionné le procureur bibi
downer alors pour beaucoup c'est une
affaire quand même très politique parce
que se procureur Billy Dorner est
justement le même qui suit la faire
Thalès vous savez Jacob Zuma est
toujours accusé de corruption dans une
affaire de vente d'armes avec la société
française et il doit d'ailleurs se
présenter à la barre en janvier prochain
donc sanctionné Billy downer serait se
débarras de cette affaire qui le
poursuit depuis des années en Afrique du
Sud le politique et le judiciaire
s'entremêle sérieusement et ça n'est pas
près de s'arrêter
c'était le 5 septembre 2021 des
militaires puccistes renversaient le
président guinéen Alpha Condé plusieurs
de ses collaborateurs sont alors
emprisonnés sans jugement 15 mois plus
tard leur proche demande toujours leur
libération à Conakry les précisions de
Malik Diakité
selon leurs avocats avec qui nous avons
pu échanger plusieurs projets
collaborateurs de l'ex-président Alpha
Condé ont vu leur état de santé se
dégrader de plus près de 8 mois
Ibrahima kassouri qui était son ancien
Premier ministre Amadou Damaro Camara
son ancien président de l'Assemblée
nationale et plusieurs autres cadres
sont incarcérés à la prison centrale de
Conakry ils sont poursuivis par la Cour
de répression des infractions
économiques et financières pour des
faits présumés de détournement de
dernier public leur détention prolongée
et sans jugement inquiète l'organisation
guinéenne de défense des droits de
l'Homme cela constitue un abus quand
même sur la gloire parce que ça fait
plus de huit mois maintenant et elles
sont en détention est réclame un procès
et ne bénéficie pas beaucoup dans quelle
demande même d'être aussi placé sous
contrôle judiciaire pour pouvoir en tout
cas être soigné comme vous le savez les
conditions carcérales chez nous elles
sont difficiles et ne répondent plus pas
souvent aux normes internationales en
matière de détention nous estimons quand
même qu'il faut faire face à leur
situation et pour ne pas qu'il soit trop
tard pour rappel de plus de 4 mois au
marsilla alias phonique manga et
Ibrahima Diallo de leader du fndc Front
national pour la défense de la
Constitution opposée à la gestion de la
transition militaire en cours sont aussi
détenus à la présence centrale de
Conakry en attente de leur procès
chose promise chose due le premier
épisode de notre série consacrée au
Soudan un an après le coup d'État
militaire son économie est au plus mal
taux d'inflation qui dépasse les 100%
hausse des taxes et des prix avec en
toile de fond la guerre en Ukraine qui
évidemment n'arrange rien les Soudanais
ont de quoi être sur les nerfs reportage
à cartoon il est signé pour France 24
Clotilde hasard
lorsque nada va faire les courses pour
la semaine c'est toujours à crédit
j'achète le lait le sucre le thé le pain
les légumes selon mes besoins et dès que
j'ai de l'argent je rembourse les pieds
pour vivre nada vendait sandwichs dans
une école elle gagne 128 euros par mois
et paye plus de 65 € de loyer avec le
reste elle doit nourrir quatre enfants
en guise de repas quotidien des fèves et
du yaourt un plat nourrissant au bon
marché que nada n'a plus les moyens
d'agrémenter
la viande a augmenté avant c'était 89
centimes maintenant c'est un euro 30
j'ai acheté 250 g qu'on pouvait manger
sur deux jours mais plus maintenant
passons tout d'inflation annuelle de
382%, les consommateurs achètent le
strict nécessaire c'est ce que constate
cette épicier du centre-ville de cartoum
il y a des biscuits ici du sésame tous
ces produits restent ici et finissent
périmés ce qu'on achète ce sont les
produits de première comme le pain le
sucre il n'y a quasiment personne pour
acheter des sardines ou du baobab
en un an le kilo de riz est passé de 50
cm à 2 euros la gare en Ukraine a fait
bondir les prix des produits et de
l'énergie et la gente militaire privée
de l'aide internationale a augmenté
drastiquement les impôts et les taxes
les recettes de l'État ont augmenté de
145 % en 2022 en conséquence de
nombreuses entreprises fermes plongeant
l'économie au bord du gouffre
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du Soudan qu'il y a autant
d'augmentation en une seule année
augmentation des taxes mais il y a aussi
le pré d'électricité du gaz de l'essence
qui a décuplé les médicaments ont aussi
augmenté cela lourdit le budget du
citoyen toutes ces augmentations
interviennent dans une économie qui est
en récession
serait une meilleure exploitation des
ressources naturelles du pays comme les
terres fertiles ou l'or du golf font
également promis d'investir dans
l'économie en novembre l'Arabie Saoudite
s'est engagé à investir 3 milliards de
dollars pour aider le Soudan
elle court elle court la maladie du
sommeil au Kenya 11 millions de
personnes y sont exposées la responsable
c'est la célèbre mouche tsé elle est
présente sur un quart du territoire en
Afrique subsaharienne ce sont quelques
trois millions d'animaux d'élevage qui
en meurent chaque année voyez le
reportage de nos correspondants
une partie de ces vaches est atteinte de
la Nagana transmise par les mouches
tsé-tsées c'est l'équivalent de la
maladie du sommeil le parasite tu chaque
année 3 millions d'animaux d'élevage en
Afrique subsaharienne
à cause de ça et elle a perdu sa
couronne
infecter les bêtes deviennent faibles et
léthargiques si elles ne sont pas
traitées elles en meurent
le foyer s'est développé dans le parc
national voisin
cet endroit le parc est un lieu de
reproduction pour la mouche tsé-tsé cela
a donc un impact négatif sur nos revenus
et sur les personnes qui vivent autour
du parc
malgré des foyers dans différentes
régions du Kenya aucun humain n'est mort
dans le pays ces 20 dernières années
les autorités locales sont tout de même
très préoccupées
toujours le bétail montre que l'homme
est encore menacé
est toujours réelle
dans ce laboratoire de Nairobi les
chercheurs multiplient les expériences
ils ont récemment créé des répulsifs et
des pièges il travaille en ce moment sur
un test rapide destiné aux fermiers
la maladie chez les animaux et les
protéger contre de nouvelles infections
il faut également réduire le nombre de
mouches afin de limiter leur contact
avec les animaux il s'agit d'une
approche multiple
des recherches primordiales pour le
continent
chaque année la mouche tsé-tsé coûte à
l'Afrique environ 4,5 milliards d'euros
allez pour finir ce journal on prend la
direction du Nigéria pour la quatrième
édition du slump Party c'est un festival
des bidons villes organisé à Lagos son
but mettre en valeur l'arme aussi la
danse chez les jeunes des quartiers les
images vous sont commentées par Laurent
Berchet
les corps enduits de craie comme prêt à
partir en guerre il laisse éclater un
cri de détresse avant de se lancer dans
un pas de danse sous les yeux envoûtés
du public
pour cette quatrième édition du slum
parti l'ambiance est à la fête dans ce
bidon ville de legos un festival ou
l'art et la danse sont aussi des outils
de réflexion
il y avait une dinde on associe la danse
à d'autres disciplines artistiques la
littérature l'art contemporain est
visuels
on s'adresse à la communauté pour parler
de différents problèmes sociaux et
politiques en utilisant la fête comme
point de départ
[Musique]
nigériane la violence et la criminalité
sont omniprésentes une violence que l'on
retrouve également dans ses performances
pour les organisateurs du festival la
danse doit permettre aux jeunes de
canaliser leurs émotions négatives et de
se réapproprier leur quartier
un échappatoire qui peut aussi ouvrir
des portes comme pour gift aisé qui se
dit transformé par cette expérience
ce festival a vraiment changé beaucoup
de choses pour moi j'ai pu développer ma
créativité ma manière de danser mais
aussi de voir le monde
alors que les festivités touchent alors
faim le public se joint au danseur pour
une ultime communion où chacun laisse
éclater sa créativité
[Musique]
voilà donc pour ces quelques pas de
danse à Lago c'est la fin de ce journal
de l'Afrique restez avec nous
l'information continue bien sûr sur
France 24
[Musique]